i think uh matt's taking exactly the
right decision
um it's okay having the uh support
and the confidence of the prime minister
but in a pandemic you've also got to
have the support and the confidence of
the public
and although i think they had some
sympathy with him over the affair
it wasn't that it was the perceived
hypocrisy
of telling people to do one thing and
doing another yourself and breaking the
rules
and that has made his position untenable
as health secretary because i say you've
got to have
the confidence and belief of the people
and mata sadly lost that
shouldn't he have just gone yesterday
rather than dragging it out and getting
the prime minister to give him his
support
with hindsight he probably should um
although we're quite near the end of the
panda epidemic and i'm sure that he
wanted to see it out but
at the end of the day it's okay having
the prime minister's confidence the
health secretaries got to have the
public confidence and it became apparent
overnight
that the newspapers were going to
continue printing headlines
that were undermining public confidence
and obviously
colleagues such as myself our inboxes
were filling up with constituents who
um were calling for him to go and
we've seen this before and his position
became completely
untenable what can you say to
uh constituents then who have been
emailing you can you defend what's
happened
well i was on the media yesterday and i
said that um
as far as i was concerned it was a
private matter however
if matt hancock believed that uh the
situation he got himself in
had undermined his ability to perform
his duties as health secretary he should
have resigned
and if the prime minister thought that
matt hancock's
performance of his role had been
undermined then he should have sacked
him
clearly that wasn't the case um matt had
apologized for
breaking the social distancing rules but
but clearly when you're
not just having to abide by the rules
but you're making the rules yourself
that puts him in an invidious position
and you know the accusations of
hypocrisy were there for all to see
and really his position was untenable
wasn't it i mean growing calls
from the opposition but now more and
more conservative
mps saying he couldn't stay
yeah so i've spent the day with
volunteers up
in batley and spend at the by-election
and and clearly the issue with
matt hancock had dominated the headlines
for the last uh
more than 24 hours and it was a topic on
on the doorstep
and um i think people had some sympathy
for him they think he's done a pretty
good job during the
in an however
i come back to my point during a
pandemic in particular it's absolutely
essential that
the the health secretary had the
confidence of the vast majority of the
public
and clearly he'd lost that in the last
24 hours that means
he had to resign what do you think of
matt hancock as uh
health secretary do you think he did an
effective job he's has he had your
confidence
i've not agreed with some of the issues
he's taken the
linking of my constituency with the city
of leicester for
lockdown local lockdown purposes
basically condemned
my constituents whatever they did that
they were going to be in lockdown
pretty much continuously um i would have
lifted
the restrictions of the lockdown
probably far earlier than he has but
they've gone for a cautious
approach fortunately for this country
the procurement and roll out of the
vaccine has been such an excellent job
compared to our competitor economies
the government's been able to have the
luxury they see of uh
of a very uh cautious lifting of the
lockdown procedures
i'm afraid i i do think that the the
cost of lockdown has not been
calculated yet the cost of mental health
well-being the backlog of cases in the
for the nhs uh and that's going to take
a lot of dealing with
um i'm i think we'll be very skeptical
about using lockdowns as a prevention
measure to control uh situations that
we've been in for the last 80 months
when we get the full reports of of how
that has damaged our society and our
economy
and of course this week in england we
were supposed to have so-called freedom
day
on the 21st of june and here we are
talking about the health secretary or
now
the now departed health secretary in
indeed and i think
uh what what the government had to roll
back on is that the figures that we were
given
i didn't vote for extending lockdown i
voted against it
uh the other week but those figures were
spurious they were they were outdated
data and uh that we've broken through
vaccination
excellent vaccination process we've
broken the link between infections
and hospitalizations and and fantastic
we're not having the level of fatalities
conservative mps many don't like matt
hancock do they
um everybody in politics you know
there's an old saying in particular
if you want a friend in politics get
yourself a job and
one thing for sure in politics when
you're when you're in trouble like matt
hancock is um
there aren't many friends about
unfortunately
perhaps the prime minister now i want to
ask you what damage this might have done
then to the government's chinese we've
got this by-election as you mentioned
battery and spend coming up on thursday
how much damage has been done well i was
out
up in bathing spend with my volunteers
three weeks ago and
i've spent the day up there today and uh
it doesn't feel a deal different um i
think the conservatives
have got every chance of winning that
that seat
um and the labour activists i saw looked
fairly demoralized
up in the constitution